uh really excited to be here it's a
privilege to be here among the this
fantastic HCI Community who've been
pushing the boundaries of HC for many
many years and to be among these young
new generation of HCI enthusias who who
are going to build the future of
HCI so I'm excited to talk to you about
my current work on harnessing data for
social good or social impact empowering
communities through visualization and
social
Computing
uh as Michael said very correctly my
pronunciation is narus Mahar my name
pronunciation and uh currently I'm at
Harvard as a Harvard Ratliff fellow but
I'm a Yas ammer uh and I'm co-founder
and co-director of hdi's Lab at UMAS
speaking of the lab Ali I established
the lab in 2020 with only two PhD
students and I'm so proud to see the lab
has been growing with having more than
24 active members and many alumni and we
focus on research on socially impactful
technologies that Empower data informed
decision
making you can see the the website for
more information on our projects and
people and
Publications the structure of my talk
for today is I'll start by presenting a
short introduction about my work
motivating my work and where I am and
what I'm doing and then I'll briefly
talk about a few selected projects H and
finally I'll describe my vision for
future work h and a call to action uh
and with that I hope I can inspire you
to join our team to make this Vision to
reality through
collaboration in terms of research we
are a very interdisciplinary research
lab we conduct both fundamental as well
as applied research at the intersection
of visualization social Computing design
and more and more nowadays applied uh
machine learning and AI however HCI or
human- centered Computing serves as this
overarching principle that shapes all of
my work within a very deeply human
centered framework and with our work
with Community we extend the human
centered Computing to community centered
Computing when we try to understand the
needs and challenges of community and
design and build technology for
them in terms of domain area I've been
working on Urban Planning and
placemaking Building tools and
technology for bringing people to these
very complex matters I have built
several Partnerships with city or town
officials uh and groups in across uh
Vancouver British Columbia to San Diego
AMS and nowadays
Boston also text visual analytics is
another domain that I've been working on
in financial data analysis and nowadays
more and more uh on Building Technology
for bringing awareness and education
around climate
change to give you an idea of like where
I'm coming from and the research areas
that I'm been working on here are the
main directions of my research with some
selected work so visual analytics is um
was the focus of my PhD where you might
be able to look at those small tum lades
and see like large interactive surfaces
where where I was building technology
and visual analytic tools enabling a
group of experts and analy anal go
through complex data and solve it
collaboratively and uh more effectively
and nowadays we're still working with
visual analytics but with the focus of
increasing the coverage of data and
basically balancing and mitigating
biases in the analysis
process okay until a month before I used
to say during the past nine years but
now I can say during the past decade
I've been and shift my focus on
addressing complex socio technical
problems uh and my team and I have been
building and studying what I call
Community centered tools for increasing
public engagement in massive Civic
decision making processes and today I'm
mostly going to focus on this line of
work but I'm happy to chat offline about
any other line of my
work another line of work my work is
what I like to call visualization for
empowerment and by that I mean uh
building visualization tools and making
data visualization and Analysis
accessible for empowering a broader
audience including the public the
general public to understand and explore
the data that is increasingly part of
their lives and we've seen it during the
covid pandemic and many other situation
where people need visualization to make
informed decisions personally or
collectively
speaking of soot technical problems as
uh don Norman
Ander um write in this article soot
technical problems are complex
multifaceted problems that are difficult
to solve due to their interconnectedness
and shifting Natures making them very
difficult to sort out cause and effect
and solve uh examples are systems such
as health care or Transportation or
governmental policy and Environmental
Protection and
sustainability they're also known as
vicked problem anybody has heard of
vicked problem before lovely in this
classic article retail and Leber in 1973
coined the term Wicket problem and they
talked about you know complex problems
such as planning problems uh and their
wickedness and how and why
difficult so they Define 10 different
characteristics of wicked problems but
mainly they are unstructured they're
difficult to sort out cause and effect
and therefore they are more difficult
than other type of problems to solve
they're cross cutting meaning they have
a lot of overlapping stakeholders and
why it becomes more difficult to solve
because the stakeholders come from
different background different
objectives uh different Orient
orentation and therefore it becomes a
very messy a very conflicting space to
be able to solve a problem and they're
Relentless they can't be solved once and
for all whatever decision that you make
makes one group unhappy while makes the
other group happy it's very very
difficult so one way to tame Wicked
problem is to engage all the
stakeholders in community so Community
engagement is really the key because it
helps to raise awareness a lot of time
the community itself do not have
awareness or education about those
problems and it causes a lot of tension
and
friction um to tap into their local
knowledge they have a lot of valuable
knowledge that the policy makers and
decision makers don't know and then
ultimately it encourage encourages
collaboration and co-creation among all
of these stakeholders to come up with
viable Solutions
there's a big problem here though
Community engagement has been a problem
for over a century especially in the
US so in this article Enis and Booher
talk about how con conventional public
engagement especially in the US and
especially uh public hearings review and
comment procedures not only do not meet
the most basic uh goals for public
participation
but they're also counterproductive they
cause anger mistrust and even Revolt
anybody has been to a public meeting
before yes a handful as you as you might
have seen similar to this picture only a
handful of people get to stand up and
raise their voice and bring their
comments but many others who have
already invested coming to these
meetings do not get to share their ideas
and feedback which is a big problem
so I want to mention that there are so
many different challenges around public
engagement and public participation in
this talk I refer to some of the main or
grand challenges that my research has
been trying to address first is
enhancing engagement of the participants
the one who are already engaged enough
to make it to a public meeting or
Workshop but there is no means to
further and more meaningfully engaging
them engaging reticent participants
again the one that are actively engaged
who made it to those public hearing but
as I we just spoke during those Town
Hall meetings they don't get to speak up
and they remain
silent scaling participation which has
been the very big quest of Mind how we
can scale participation Beyond those
white affluent educated Publications
populations who are usually part of
these
meetings and then another big and more
underexplored problem is how to record
and analyze these what I called precious
public inputs and utilize them in the
actual decisions at the
end these are the selected projects that
I'm going to go over briefly today and
each of them is trying to at least
address one of the problems that I just
mentioned so let's start with Udi spaces
for enhancing engagement of participants
UD spaces is shorted for Urban Design
collaborative spaces and as you can see
through this picture it's a tabletop
centered multi-display environment for
engaging the public in the very complex
matter of Urban Design This was a
long-term interdisciplinary project
between computer science and
architecture department at UBC where I
worked as a
postto as a postto coming to this very
new field I started delving into to the
literature to understand like Urban
studies and the computational support
and the more I delve the more I found
there is a lack of tool support during
these design shetes or design you know
active uh participation meeting
especially for integrating data and
visualization of information to enable
people to understand more tangibly what
they're talking about to employ those
interactive modes to engage people more
more interactively and then employing
social and peer learning which we all
know is very important for bringing
people um to these areas and the absence
of visualization and computer support
tools for planning and public engagement
marked a turning point in my career um
10 years ago that makes and inspired a
shift uh in my focus towards the
development of tools for for this
domain therefore our research questions
were around how to build collaborative
technology and visualization techniques
to engage diverse set of exp uh
stakeholders to Foster collaboration and
co-creation among them and more
importantly to increase their
understanding of the impact of their
design
traces so here's the tabletop interface
at Each corner there's a case bar where
user can explore different buildings
which they call them cases in urban
planning and they can get their
information whenever they're ready with
their choice they can simply drag and
drop it on an interactive map on the
table they can position it where they
want and then the spatial results are
displayed in sort of 3D on a project on
the wall to enable them to see a better
you know
uh in a better way and there are
handheld devices that are connected to
this ecosystem that enables first remote
interaction with a table with a wall
display and we also buil a visualization
dashboard that allows people to choose
and drag and drop in a very simple
interaction ma matter the metrics or
indicators of Urban Design that matters
and is more important for the team and
it's all basically as you might be be
able to see dynamically change as people
adding more to their design of um the
the map on the
table we conducted a formal evaluation
which I'm not going through the detail
but we compared our digital tool versus
a formal paper a paper based version and
we try to make them as similar as
possible in terms of the map the
highlights the building information that
we gave to each team member and so on
and some interesting results in a very
summary format one very interesting
observation was that the tabletop and
this digital
ecosystem increased the equity of access
to design materials what do I mean in a
paper based version we saw some people
guarding their design just like this
because either they had more knowledge
of Urban Design than other team members
or they didn't want anyone to mess with
their Perfect Design the time was short
versus in the digital form it was so
easy to do and redo and to see and
discuss together as a team and finally
come up with a decision as one of the
participants said having this tabletop
got every stakeholder involved so they
can make changes themselves see those
changes right away which promotes
collaboration another observation was
the multi-display environment catalyzed
discussion we observed many instances
where the team member were looking at
the wall and the 3D explaining and going
through how this neighborhood is going
to look like with these new builds and
one said I definitely really liked how
everything was synced especially with
regards to 3D iPad and table itself but
most importantly one of our goals in
this project was to bring the ability of
visualization to enhance people's Visual
and
analytics uh and also to add a personal
space in this very shared you know uh
space collaborative space to enable
people to basically look at the data in
their own time while adding those iPads
to these ecosystem and as you might be
able to go to see through this picture
we saw many instances when people were
looking and checking their metrics on
the iPad and they were adjusting their
their design accordingly
and based on our results the digital
group came up with more informed
decisions afterwards due to having this
you know analytical
dashboard one said having indicators in
real time definitely altered how we
approach the project we could see the
larger
impact so in terms of implication there
were a lot of implication of this
project one was this multi-touch and
natural interaction which just drag and
drop and rotate and zoom and all of this
it was really really successful for
broadening participation and engagement
so it can definitely be used in other
domains such as educations and whenever
you want to bring um a broader audience
to understanding and working with
technology we we implemented this in
three different workshops in Vancouver
with 83 people ranging from older adults
and we had visitors from high schools
all of them learned how to use the
system in less than five minutes which
was a really really good news for such a
complex tool and then having that
personal space within a shared workspace
was really really the key and important
because the version before didn't have
the personal space and we saw different
results we also wrote this paper this is
a short Workshop paper where we talk
about form factor matters and all of you
know other design criteria for building
multi-display environment from the angle
to size to rotation to everything also
one very interesting matter for me
coming from visualization perspective
was how using those infographics that
you show very briefly during that demo
uh was helpful for conveying
sustainability metrics so here's another
picture of those uh we had a team of
multimedia design students over summer
who designed all of these infographics
in the middle of those donut charts to
be able to convey a lot of these metrics
without much labeling and it was very
very effective it was so effective that
it sparked my interest to run an actual
experiments and scientific study to
understand whether or not infographics
hinder or doesn't hinder or maybe
improve people's understanding because
there has been some connotations
negative connotations around
infographics in the visualization
community and the good news
was it the infographic help people to
Envision the topic better without
sacrificing understanding comparing to
the actual abstract uh abstract
visualization so with that I'm going to
move to the next project which is
community uh click for engaging reticent
participants and it's a system for
capturing and Reporting Community
feedback from town halls to improve
inclusivity we called it Community click
because we basically um brought eye
clickers to town hall with one important
modification and that was making the
feedback in real time so you don't have
to pull people at any they can bring
their feedback at any given time and
this is based on the success factor of
iar in education which has shown to
increase student students engagement
with a with a
material this was the work of my former
PhD student Mahmud Jim along with two
Master students Amy Zong and Ali
sarwat so again back to our picture and
Town Hall meetings their common methods
still in the US for hearing from the
public understanding their requirements
needs and issues ideally you would want
all the attendees in such meetings to
bring their comments and ideas and
suggestions questions and questions uh
but only a handful uh get to bring their
ideas due to fear of public speaking uh
fear of Confrontation language barrier
shortage of time and so many other
barriers furthermore the organizers
struggle to facilitate the meeting and
capture attende these feedback at the
same time and they have to run the
meeting manage discussion collect data
sometimes resolve conflict and as as a
result of all of those activity a lot of
time those precious public input gets
lost during this process and doesn't get
utilized in the actual decisions with
that our research questions we're
focused on addressing these two problems
how do we Empower attendees in
particular those silent fraction to
express their opinion and how can we
enable organizers to come up with more
comprehensive uh reports at the
end so here are um some different set of
eye clickers that we use as you can see
we have labeled them the blue one was
for organizers to to say here's a main
issue or here's a new idea that the
community are bringing and we we haven't
been thinking about and the gray one for
the attendees is to say I agree or I
disagree or I am unsure about anything
that you're talking about right at this
moment naras or this is important or I'm
confused and all of these were based on
formative studies that we done with both
uh communities and we created I click a
recorder to uh basically record all the
input in real
time and then here I want to show you
the um the workflow of community click
which basically we gather all of the
meeting attendees through I clickers as
well as organizers and we use
off-the-shelf tools to to automatically
record and basically transcribe all of
these meeting notes so nothing gets lost
we have a long list of meeting notes and
then we put them all together to what I
call augmented transcript because it's
augmented with all of these feedback
from attendees and organizers and then
we on topic extractions and we build a
very specific text summarizer and we
feed all of these input into our visual
analytic interace face which offers a
wide range of uh features for exploring
this meeting content and generating
comprehensive report so here's how it
looks like as I said it has several
components they're all interl and
interactive and provides a wide array of
features here are some main features for
example the organizer tags can be used
as filters for example you're an
organizer you want to go through this
very long list team meeting report you
say I want to look at main issue and by
checking the main issue from that list
you basically filter and just see the
main issue we also built this timeline
which shows the basically distribution
of organizers tags over time for example
you're like I remember towards the end
of that meeting there was a main issue
so you can click on that red dot at the
end of the timeline to get to that exact
um issue you're thinking of and then
this is the augmented meeting transcript
that provides a meeting discussion
segment with Associated text organizers
tags as well as distribution of
attendees meeting for that chunk of um
meeting notes and then finally this is
the uh interactive feedback weighted
summary that we built and act as an
anchor for them to explore all of these
meeting notes we deployed committee
click in the town hall meeting in ammer
on issues of parking in downtown and
there were 33 attendees we gave them 5
minutes tutorial of how to use uh the
iers and we handed them I clickers and
we surveyed them at the end here I want
to show you the
result so first we ask them if they feel
comfortable in general not with clickers
to share their thoughts during public
meeting and as you can see people were
split those people at the top were felt
at ease to speak up and to bring their
ideas to the meeting they had no
problems and there were some people at
the bottom uh left um that um didn't
feel comfortable sharing and then we
asked them if I clicker help them to
share their thoughts and here's where we
saw a major shift
watch those people who felt comfortable
and easy speaking didn't hate or dislike
ier that much some EV liked to have both
channels to verbally speaking but also
you know providing some feedback but
here's where you can see the major shift
you see those people at the very bottom
who didn't feel comfortable speaking
found to be very much empowered by this
technology and this where the exact
group we were building the tool one of
the comments from attendees on the
survey was your tool empowered me to
share my feedback silently
which became part of the paper of course
and then there are a lot of implication
of this work that we talked in the
discussion and this work from how these
low barrier technology are important for
bringing people to democratic decision
making to building inclusive platforms
um and so on and we also talk about
anonymity and and privacy and so many
other issues that I want to
just for the sake of time move to the
next project just a quick clarification
was there any time any kind of real time
feedback to the people who were using
the clicker or was it sort of a silent
signal thank you I have it here I didn't
want to uh yes augmenting with more
realtime component due to a lot of
research that shows if you show the
results right away you can bias people
if you say like 70% are in disagreement
with whatever narus is talking about it
could just change the the room
temperature also we decided not to show
anything and we didn't want to
complicate uh or basically distract
people from listening to the speakers in
the room or the uh town hall meeting
like topic whatever but we are talking
about how or might we might augment it
with more real there was no real time I
see so the so the changes were entirely
based on sort of a one-way communication
where they they had the cter they were
pushing things but they didn't get any
feedback on it they still felt more
comfortable doing yes okay yes very good
question and the journey of community
click didn't end here we build a virtual
version of it and we deployed it in cscw
conference which is one of the
conferences in our field with 700 people
in the town hall and the organizer of
the Town Hall tweeted this image
afterwards and they were like just when
you think it's all going well as you can
see about 70% of people were confused
about matters which were discussed and
then of course afterwards the pandemic
hit and the town of amers which we
deployed the tool very interested in
deploying the system and they were like
can you build a virtual version and we
were yes we already build the virtual
version here you go use it and here's of
course a picture from one of those you
know deployment they use it which showed
to
basically increase and tripling the
engagement during the zoom meeting but
of course they did didn't accept it
right away we worked with them six
months very closely to build the to
change the the system in the way that is
easier for them as non-technical people
to go over all of the meeting we even
added the the video to this you know uh
tool and a stream of visualization to be
able for them we also added the chat
message and a lot of other features that
we talk about in this uh short Workshop
paper
recently okay next that big question of
how do we scale
participation uh Community crit was
inspired by crowdsourcing methods to
engage the public at scale and enable
them to improve and evaluate ideas
rather than just merely proposing ideas
and this was part of my postto project
at UC San Diego with Steven da to give
you some background about other tools
for public participation this is plan
your place which was built for every
everyday citizen with this easy to use
map and chat you know
features but the author themselves found
it after evaluation hard for everyday
citizen to understand and use the
system there are also cross sourcing
tools which are fairly easy for the
public to use for example this one is
called vikii survey which has been
deployed in many cities like Chicago and
New York and so on and it basically ask
a pair wise question and give people
ability to bring their own comments or
ideas however research shows that people
are
tired and fed up with government asking
them about what do you want rather than
more meaningfully engage them in making
and building those plans so with those
our research questions were around how
can we create a system for activities
Beyond opinion polling that captures
quality feedback in a short amount of
time knowing that citizens don't have a
lot of time to spare for these these
matters and we began by attending a
local design workshop and planning
meetings we took notes during a street
tour attended the workshop my team is
here I'm actually sitting on uh on the
table and my team is there my intern
student Michel Inc who's now a PhD
students here uh was there actually
recording all of the conversations as
well and based on all of these formative
work we built Community crit which is
available online and in order to lower
the barrier for the public it works on
variety of devices including smartphones
and it starts by giving people an idea
about the placemaking challenge that
they're talking about in this case we
were partnering with a team in San Diego
to redesign uh San Diego's downtown
neighborhood then gives a short
background about the design problem we
focus on this key intersection in
downtown San Diego and then it
structures a process where participant
choose an idea this idea can come from
those public workshops where we went to
and recorded all of the ideas or online
through our system and then it only ask
people five questions for the matter of
Simplicity five questions such as
critique the idea based on these certain
considerations or rating the concept on
different dimensions and then to collect
meaningful feedback here we provided the
option of skipping questions if they
wanted to and then they can also submit
their own ideas give it a name and add a
picture for it and at the end they they
see a full set of
ideas they can repeat this process as
many time as they
want so after deploying the tool in San
go for 4 weeks we received
352 contributions from 39 commune
members which from the Planning Group we
were work on was a huge huge win and we
interviewed people who participated and
they were like I don't have time to go
to workshops so it provides opportunity
to give feedback for me and others
praising about this five questions and
how easy and straightforward it was to
do but the main country ution of this
work to me were scaling and diversifying
public participation and creating a
complimentary tool to public Workshop
that allowed meaningful input from
public in a short amount of time and
connecting these small group who attend
public Workshop to a much larger group
who can use technology to add uh their
ideas to
this and then there are a lot of
implications again on this work about
how we can apply crowdsourcing in
citizen sourcing and like what are the
differences how can uh we basically
build a tool in a way that is
straightforward and easy to use but also
gather um meaningful feedback from the
public but then at the end one of the
feedback that we received from the
Planning Group which were comprise of
community leaders architect uh were like
this is fantastic this is a really nice
tool very clear UI all of the comments
are there we can go to different
proposal but to be honest we don't have
time to go through all of these comments
and their ask was like can you build a
magic tool we don't know what it is that
but we want a magic tool to see the
pulse of
community and of course what we did next
was we built Community pulse to show the
pulse of community and to help them to
analyze and utilize public
input this is another work from my
former PhD student Mahmud Jim inamul hog
and Ali Sarat and it's a visual analytic
tools for facilitating Community input
analysis so the problem is beyond the
urban planning group that we work with
in reality and we've done another you
know uh very in-depth across the US with
Civic leaders grappling with analyzing
um Community input and it's all the same
the vast amount of community input
through online platform um enabled them
to collect a large number of community
input and while analyzing these input is
vital for making Democratic decision and
they um struggle to analyze them due to
lack of time analytical skills and
specialized tools
and I want to add that there are also
inherent challenges of analyzing Text
data that makes it even more complex one
is the high dimensionality of Text data
in general the lack of structure in this
case when you don't have document but
you should have short free form comments
the ambiguity and all of these get
intensifies in the Civic domains uh when
also people are using informal language
and also there is an un clear boundary
between positive and negative uh opinion
and of course HTI faults have been
working on um Building Solutions for
analyzing public opinions for example
consider tool is a great example uh
which helps Civic conversation to stay
focused by providing a con a pro and con
list which is Visual and very
straightforward however it's harder to
analyze people's needs and priorities
and issues in this procon list and there
are visual analytic tools like convin it
which is um very very powerful in
showing all of these opinion of the
author and the topic and the sentiment
but as you can see through this picture
is very much expert Centric right so
with that we built community puls in a
manner that it's very easy for any Civic
leader who's not an expert in visual
analytics to easily go through and see
the pulse of community so it has this
overview which shows the number of
proposal which is again from Community
crit so same data from actual community
members uh the key phrases topic
extraction and so on but most
importantly here's this interactive
visualization which is interactive and
Link so anywhere uh you can you can
click and interact with it and we
implement mented an emotion classifier
because all of the Civic leaders we
talked about they said we don't want
sentiment analysis it doesn't make sense
for us we want something beyond that we
want to see the reaction of people do
they hate it do they love it why do they
hate it and so on and we we we basically
build a transform based Transformer
based birth model uh to basically show
all of these uh emotions here and then
wean study with Civic leaders and not
surprisingly all of them started by
filtering based on Angry comments and
again nons
surprisingly the roundabout was the
first you know proposal that most people
hate it because people have a lot of
problems uh around building
roundabouts and then if they click on
those angry bar comments they get to see
the detail comments so basically
provides at a glance an
overview uh of emotions and reactions of
people but they can also dig down and
drill down to see what are those
comments where are they coming from why
they're angry or why they're happy with
it and then again implications of this
work was exactly extracting Community
reactions rather than sticking to
sentiment analysis uh having this
multifaceted exploration of community
input from this overview to detail to be
able to even verify and validate those
uh and to support te on Savvi domain
experts which came up over and over in
our
interviews so to wrap up I wanted to
bring this work very quickly which is a
multi-year work or perhaps better to to
mention maybe around five years it took
us to come up with this open Civic
framework and this was an attempt based
on all of our efforts in building
Community Center tools to come up with a
theoretical framework to say if you're a
technologist here's how you can perhaps
start with Building Technology and in
order to build that we looked at
previous framework in spaces of public
participations and design thinking and
cross sourcing and we combine them all
together to basically come up with this
framework and basically we use our tools
that we built and Showcase in our
evaluation showcase success in terms of
talking about where you provide support
in in person meetings where you Pro
where you can provide support in uh in
an online manner for people to gather
idea and how we can provide support for
analyzing all of this
together so this was a wrap up of the
project I wanted to go through but in
terms of Future Vision a significant
portion of our research has concentrated
on encouraging communities to prioritize
the creation of healthy places like
these healthy Community plac making
walkable bikable neighborhoods and so on
and um recently we have extended our
research to Encompass the development of
Healthy Communities ranging from
studying the impact of covid-19 on small
town communities to thinking about you
know how we can build Ai and chat Bots
for Parkinson disease patients and so on
but then I now I aspire to to further
broaden our research scope to Encompass
more extensive topics that can further
Advance democracy Equity well-being and
sustainability by including Tech
oriented approaches for fostering
healthier planet and thinking about
critical areas of HCI such as un
sustainable development plans in health
poverty education and sustainability and
with that I want to invite you to join
us in making this Vision by uh
collaboration Vision
happen so we are also
venturing uh to more work uh
investigating critical views on
inclusive and responsible visualization
for example how does visualization
influence societal perception decision
making process and the construction of
knowledge for example in this work uh we
for the first time argued that the
analytical orientation in current text
visualization leaves less attention for
accounting for the political nature of
Civic text
visualization and with all the surveys
and results that we showcased we came up
and proposed five different conceptual
Dimensions each discussing discussing
two different polls that challenges the
overall analytical orientation by
discussing design choices for example
what it means to design tools to address
the complexity of the problem on one
hand and what it means to also uh
imagine inclusivity those people who are
not t text savvy are relieving them by
bringing so much complexity and some
sometimes complex problems need complex
solution but we need to always think
about this balance right or what it
means to aggregate data which usually
leads to marginalization versus
articulations and we discuss all of
these different polls in this work and
we also venturing to integrate AI by
asking questions like how can AI be
harnessed for positive social impact in
context of community and development and
environmental
sustainability for example in this
project uh our theory is called
Community Bots and it's a chatbot
community that talk with the Community
member to
elicit Rich uh and multifaceted data
around different facets of their life
and how it has been impacted by covid
and our thesis our idea here was if you
can mimic the way that people talk to
experts uh with chatbot and they can
consider there's a chatbot that is um
expert in in work and there's a chatbot
that is expert to health you can connect
you can gather more Rich data which our
data and our analysis uh basically
supported this
hypothesis and then how can we create
engaging and accessible data
communication methods to actively engage
Community with very complex matters uh
Beyond traditional approaches of
visualizations and technology for
example in this work in Rising emotions
we combine data physicalization
an art installation to show the public
feelings about the sea level rise which
is happening very soon in East
Boston and we basically survey East
Boston residents about their feeling
towards this happening in their
neighborhood we color coded their
emotions and with the help of community
members so these colors you see those
colorful ribbons are actual data points
from the public and with the help of
public members our team in install this
art installation in front of the East
Boston Library which is a very visible
place uh for the community but also a
gathering place for the community of
East Boston and we had an opening
exhibition in December
2020 uh which brought people from from
the city to to speak we we brought
scientists from ums Boston to talk about
climate change and flooding effect H and
it proved to be successful in increasing
engagement and awareness around climate
change issues and I like to continue
working on this work I actually brought
this postcards not perhaps for all of
you but feel free to to gather some
which talks about the project and uh
adds more detail about what we did in
this work and then after that I started
thinking about okay this was really
great but how can we build technology to
bring awareness about these difficult
matters of climate change especially
with those underserved communities and
in this recent work my postto and a
group of Robotics researchers at Cornell
developed and evaluated a first of its
kind communal extended reality because
it happens during a bus tour when we had
the community in a bus tour and wearing
those head mounted uh augmented reality
headset to see the future of their
neighborhood basically in the sidu and a
result exemplifies that geolocated
virtual reality can be a powerful tool
to motivate Innovation and Collective
actions and this was a first of its kind
empirical contribution showing that this
sort of community extended reality where
you bring Community together to see and
discuss all of these impact together uh
can Inspire actions and based on that
the project that I'm currently
undertaking at Ratcliffe uh is an
extension of that thinking about making
it even a more low barrier technology
what if we build a web based augmented
reality and then we integrate it with
situated visualization so that people
can just walk around the
neighborhood scan this QR code from our
platform walk around and see the sea
level rise and what's happening in East
Boston and through those visualization
slider they can see through different
years so make it as tangible and as easy
and low barrier as possible to empower
the community especially those
underserved one who don't have the
luxury and time to see and explore these
problems to become part of climate
discourse in action
plans and I want to acknowledge that
these project s were all collaborative
collaborative effort thank my amazing
mentors collaborators and fantastic
student uh UMAS and Beyond and with that
I'm happy to take any
questions all right yeah we have a few
few moments for questions feedback
comments well I'd like to to kick off
with
is a question of the distinction
between beinging being heard and feeling
heard um so scaling
participation generally does in sort of
a statistical sense mean that you can be
heard right you know AB graphs that say
this many people agree or disagree or or
or anything like that and I want but it
doesn't necessarily mean that you feel
heard right like I think this was sort
of the the implication of uh you know
you're just having us do opinion surveys
absolutely um it seems to me like
feeling hurt is often a feature of um a
kind of expensive quote unquote thing
for say the policy maker to do which is
like I sat here and listened to you for
20 minutes or five minutes or you gave
your comment so I'm wondering about if
there are ways to if we're leaving this
notion of feeling heard behind and if
there are ways that these kinds of
systems that you're developing might let
us feel both ways right fantastic
question thank you so much this was
definitely a question we were we were
asking even during the community crit
project that people felt empowered
because they didn't have another Channel
another way to bring their ideas but
definitely being heard is where they see
their ideas and comments are actually
implemented in the policy and to that
note I need to say that's another Wicked
problem because we've been working very
hard to connect with Community to
connect with government officials to
town officials to make sure that all of
these comments
and and valuable you know inputs That We
Gather from the committee gets actually
implemented but it's a really really
messy process for example in community
crit um the Planning Group were very
very excited about the work they did
with us and they wrote along you know
plans after words based on all of these
and submitted to the city to be honest I
left because uh I just got a job at UMAS
amers and I we didn't follow up much of
how much of that actually change and
circulating this back to the community
and saying that okay from those very
very
idealistic plans that are Urban plan ERS
or architect at at the at the first now
we're changing to these plans that the
community wanted collectively really
really but it we've been looking for a
new PhD students to basically I call it
the later phase of the decision- making
processes like first to engage them to
bring them in different ways from online
to in person and then finally how can
and it's the idea that open Civics talks
about how can we bring Community to also
help Civic leaders in prioritizing
making those plans to actually feel and
be heard uh so that's a whole extensive
project but absolutely great
question ask me ask me difficult
questions so when you're talking about
steering generally feel like also
tension sorry what was your yeah um can
you repeat yeah sorry so yeah when you
like do a lot of like when you're
talking about scale there's often a
contention with you and Community um so
like how have you like thought about
reconciling that difference and trying
to you know do the scaling and try to
reach a bunch of different communities
but at the same time making sure that
like you know anything that you build is
specific Niche for like the needs of
specific people that absolutely great
question question great question yes
definitely it's very important for you
especially when you're doing this online
engagement to understand where the
community is coming from are they the
one who want to Rally the powerful group
that were always engaged and again are
coming to this online space to rally for
their ideas because they have uh more
power they're more technology oriented
are you also hearing from those unders
Ser community in in in community crit
for example uh we were very concerned
because this you know uh intersection
was between a very affluent neighborhood
versus a Cho neighborhood and and we had
conversation we we went to personally
Meet The Cho leader which was part of
the original workshop and he stood up
and he said you have have a lot of plans
for a community but we are not part of
it we love to be part of the design and
they were very afraid of gentrifications
and so on that there were a lot of
tension between them so we went to meet
them and we said what your community
think about online participation he said
we love it because we usually go to
these meetings we provide our feedback
nobody hears hears us so we love and we
90% more than 90% of us have access to
smartphone we love to have it but then
first first step is making sure that
they are aware and engaged and they
bringing their ideas and the next is the
point that Michael raised how do you
ensure that uh basically their comments
are heard in another effort in in I at
ammer we actually listed a crosssection
of the community and especially those
who are harder to engage from youth to
homeless to senior people to bipac to
other and we usually translate anything
that is on website uh for different
committee members where we were in
sending Diego we translated in Spanish
in AMS we translated in Chinese Spanish
uh and FY and we really try to come up
with understanding who's our local
community and how we can reach out to
them we even went to Farmers Market we
had surveys on iPad asking people we
have surveys on paper and so many other
ways to ensure that people and Community
are aware of what we're doing and we're
doing this for the benefit of them great
question thank you
yes um thanks so much for for coming and
and Shing your work with
us I think my my question is uh it seems
to a lot of your work was targeted at
making like the political process more
accessible to more like voices and
giving like you know having more people
able to respect their voices um and I
think what I'm thinking about some of
the problem about that plag our
political process
I I see like people not having a voice
of one of them but I see another problem
of some voices just being heard more
like louder than like mattering more
than other people's voices and I'm
wondering whether you see technology as
having a role whether there is a role
for technology and a problem where some
people are simply like listened to more
than other people AB your work is
addressing that problem at all
absolutely that's a that's a very
well-known problem in online space right
uh and a lot of critic on any Civic
online process has been just like
ranking and liking process which
basically gives privilege to more uh
popular opinion and those opinion that
are less popular get marginalized they
don't even get readed or so in a recent
work that I didn't present here it's
called serise short for serendipit
analysis we buil this uh bias mitigation
Mo model which uh unlike any
recommendation system that recommend any
piece of text that you have already seen
or any anything you have already seen it
recommends anything that you haven't
seen and with that it tries to mitigate
the effect of going through some popular
or like biasing towards some specific
notion of and it's for text analysis so
that's one way but that's a really
really big problem and hard problem uh
in in community PSE interestingly we
weren't thinking about this one of the
Civic leaders who went through and spent
like two weeks with Community pulse
analyzing the data said hey I noticed
this Anonymous user user
44 is the one who brings a lot of angry
comments about
roundabout so that was a way of
detecting anomalies as well like who's
also rallying there harder when it's
Anonymous to
basically you know know account for
who's coming from and making sure that
we are getting this cross you know
section of the community and so on and
that's the conversation that I recently
had uh with gosh I'm lacking on the name
on an anonymity and what are the proxies
that you can basically build into these
sort of anonymous technology to at least
like understand that these are coming
from specific uh Community intersection
all right um noting the time if you have
further feedback for nargas I suggest
either using your ey clicker or uh
coming to speak to her as as we wrap so
please thank the speaker one more
time